[Musique]
il est urgent d'éviter les politiques du
pire qui souvent finissent en pire des
politiques face au gouvernement qui
reste convaincu que sa réforme est la
bonne sondage après sondage
manifestation après manifestation la
colère ne redescend pas pour preuve elle
reste en tête dans les enquêtes mais
cette détermination puisée dans la
résignation peut-elle encore durer tous
gouvernement syndicat France qui
manifeste ou France silencieuse tous
souhaitent une issue mais chacun voyant
midi à sa porte reste inflexible sur la
question des 64 ans un premier pas une
main tendue ont été risqués sincère ou
stratégique l'invitation de la première
ministre pour ne pas être en reste face
aux propositions de Laurent Berger on
dit que Matignon s'empresse à prendre
son temps comment ne pas voir avant la
rencontre que tous première ministre
comme syndicats savent qu'ils ne vont
patienter dans la salle d'attente
jusqu'à la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel l'Inter syndicale a
accepté de venir pour enterrer la une
forme que l'exécutif entend célébré il y
a là visiblement à malentendu sur le
dress code l'inflexibilité revitalise le
bras de fer jeu de la poule mouillée
dans la littérature économique où toutes
ces intentions annoncées s'achève en
stratégie fatale le spectre du tous
piégés et perdant d'une réforme passée
dans le fracas d'un 49-3 resurgit un
flexible les français plutôt résignés
pas convaincus car la colère est
toujours là cherchant des coupables il
déjuge les politiques pour une mauvaise
gestion de la crise et retrouve un peu
confiance dans les syndicats et en
partie aussi dans l'opposition à tout le
moins le RN et Nuxe de la nesd réactions
comme autant de politiques du pire car
le constat de coût irrécupérable l'idée
de plus rien à perdre on a tant perdu de
salaire pour les grévistes de force dans
les luttes pour les syndicats il reste
convaincu aussi que le gouvernement ne
prendra pas le risque d'un recul
décrédibilisant mais on ne peut c'est le
constat confortant la flexibilité de
tous sans ignorer que ceci conduit à la
pire des politiques pour éviter le pire
il ne faut pas oublier l'économie car
lorsqu'on néglige économie souvent elle
se venge elle a frôlé la récession et
reste fragile les signes encourageant
d'un taux de chômage qui venant de 9 %
tourne autour de 7% et ce stabilisera
autour de ce point est encore loin de
l'objectif ambitieux d'un plein emploi à
5%. qui peut affirmer aujourd'hui qu'une
crise financière n'est pas une option le
desserrement d'une politique monétaire
n'est pas en vue c'est une bonne
nouvelle ni pour les investisseurs ni
pour la croissance une décision des
sages validant l'essentiel de la réforme
neutralisera les plus légitimistes CFDT
en tête réactivera des mouvements de
colère plus épars en tout cas de la part
des plus réfractaires en réponse à cette
foule qui gronde d'une colère qui
s'égare dissolution référendum usage de
l'article 10 pour relancer des
délibérations semble vain de de la part
de sortant dont le socle électoral est
déjà fragilisé un remaniement est
plébiscité dans les sondages avec
élargissement de la majorité à voir
nécessaire pour la poursuite de réforme
importante compliquée avec l'embarras
d'une alliance de LR divisé par exemple
il ne reste donc plus à Emmanuel Macron
car remercier sa première ministre et à
remanier victime d'une usure du pouvoir
précoce elle ne joue plus son rôle de
par avant n’hésitant pas au président de
sembler au terme d'un second mandat à
peine entamé il s'imposera donc le choix
d'un profil plus consensuel acteur d'une
sortie de crise rapide qui permettra
aussi d'éviter l'attentisme et
l'immobilisme des secondes mandats c'est
une question de volonté politique pour
une résilience économique s'engager à
œuvrer en transparence pour une économie
consolidée au service de français mieux
informés et en conséquence plus libre de
faire leur propre choix et peut-être
plus confiant dès lors que le politique
fera sien le conseil de Pythagore
n'entretient pas l'espoir de ce qui ne
peut être espéré
[Musique]